[Music]
we live in a small solar system in the
suburbs of the Milky Way galaxy
[Music]
eight planets and more than 180 moons
all orbiting the Sun in our solar system
the Sun is the sheriff of the town we do
whatever the Sun wants us to do the
sun's influence stretches more than one
light year in every direction and
defines the boundary of our solar system
someplace out there is a place where the
sun's influence ends and the other stars
begins that's the entrance to
interstellar space
interstellar space is the region between
star systems in our galaxy
until now we've known little about it
for so long we thought of the space in
between the stars is entirely empty but
this turns out not to be true at all
there's a lot going on out there and
it's the forefront of astronomy
one of the biggest clues about
interstellar space came right to our
doorstep October 2017 the pan-starrs one
telescope spots something unusual
pan-starrs is an observatory in Hawaii
and it's scanning large sections of the
sky looking for things that change all
of a sudden there was this tiny little
visitor just screaming through the solar
system it was going about two hundred
thousand miles an hour it was a much
faster object than what might be
expected for a solar system object and
also its trajectory was such that it
seemed like its orbit was not bound to
the Sun it was totally unlike any other
path any other trajectory any other
orbit in our solar system
astronomers reached an extraordinary
conclusion
it became very clear that yeah this was
not some solar system object falling
from a long way away this was something
that came from another star and I think
everybody was pretty amazed by that our
first known interstellar visitor on a
flyby through our solar system it was
the very first object that we had ever
discovered that had originated outside
the solar system everything else we've
seen every comment every asteroid
originated within our solar system big
mega solid object entering in our own
solar system and that's something that
you know I can only dream of
but had never thought it would actually
be a reality
scientists name the object
Omalu Hawaiian for a messenger from afar
arriving first
[Music]
this thing came from interstellar space
into our solar system and the main
question is what could it be
the object shape was mystifying it's
almost sort of shaped like a cigar it's
ten times longer than it is wide and
this is extraordinary there's no object
in our solar system that we've ever
measured that is this elongated oh
mooie-mooie
looked so unnatural it sparked
scientists imaginations one of the
things to remember about scientists is
that we're still human beings we have
read science fiction we have
imaginations I have to admit when I
first heard about it my first thought is
that it was Rama from an arthur c clarke
story rendezvous with Rama this is a
very elongated spaceship that came from
another star it reminded me of some
designs we had for interstellar
spacecrafts that have to be much longer
than they're wide in order to minimize
friction with the interstellar gas could
a mu a mu a-- be an alien interstellar
spacecraft
astronomers including professor avi Loeb
took the idea seriously we decided to
follow this object using the best
telescopes in the world and observe
whether there is any radio transmission
from it
astronomers hunted for signs of alien
communication but after eight hours of
listening across multiple frequencies
nothing
sadly no emissions were detected it's
almost certainly a natural object I
would bet all of my money on that I was
disappointed I would have been much more
excited if we have found evidence for an
alien civilization
no little green men this time ammulu ax
is a natural object but what exactly is
it at first observers thought it might
be a comet something that's mostly ice
with a little bit of rock those are the
sorts of bodies that exist really far
out from the star and are the easiest
things to eject but a comet passing this
close to the Sun would warm up turning
the ice into a gas forming a paper trail
on a Mulla Mulla astronomers saw no sign
of this happening there was no fuzziness
around it that you would expect from a
comet as the ice was turned into a gas
it was really mysterious and so
everybody who was observing it thought
it was an asteroid as team's track the
Mulla Mulla across the sky there was an
unexpected twist
as oh mooie-mooie passed through our
solar system it basically was falling in
toward the Sun speeding up immensely as
it passed the Sun before exiting the
solar system in almost the opposite
direction but then something weird
happened as it was moving away from the
Sun it was slowing down as you'd expect
but it wasn't slowing down fast enough a
Mulla Mulla gets a boost through our
solar system but how so if we think the
reason is that it's outgassing in other
words it was emitting a little bit of
gas and that was acting is a little bit
of a rocket motor push on it that's kind
of like a little jet engine on the
surface it just gives it a little thrust
over time this tiny nudge reveals a Lua
mouaz true identity
so in that case it is looking more like
a comet it's just that that emission
wasn't enough to see
powered by outgassing this interstellar
nomad might travel from star to star but
figuring out where in the galaxy it came
from just got more difficult now that we
know that o mu mu has outgassed which
changes its velocity and changes its
trajectory and makes it much harder to
do that a mu mu ax may now be safely
racing away but the solar system faces
bombardment from another interstellar
source firing at earth at close to the
speed of light cosmic rays are the
bullets of the universe and they are
flooding interstellar space